تم الانتهاء من التقدم في منصة الإطلاق
لتصريف الوقود بالكامل ،
وهناك برجان
سريان يتم دعمهما مقابل جانب
soyuz
2.1a ، يجب أن يتراجع الأول
للوقوف مؤقتًا على أهبة الاستعداد لأمر الإطلاق
، ويتراجع أول برجين سريين الآن
بمجرد أن  التراجع السري الثاني الذي
سيبدأ
أمر الإطلاق لبدء تشغيل المحرك الرئيسي ،
هناك يذهب إلى السرة الثانية لدينا
بدء تشغيل المحرك
الرئيسي لدينا مضخات توربو لبدء تشغيل المحرك الرئيسي
تصل الآن إلى سرعة الطيران
وإقلاع الإقلاع
للسفينة إعادة الإمداد 75 التقدم على  مسار سريع
لرحلة مدارية ثنائية المسار إلى محطة الفضاء الدولية
وبرنامج الانعراج في soyuz 2.1a
المنحني المنحني إلى الشمال الشرقي من قاعدة بايكونور الفضائية ،
تم الإبلاغ عن جميع المعلمات لتكون طبيعية
، حيث تحلق محطة الفضاء الدولية الآن
مباشرة فوق قاعدة
بايكونور الفضائية
يتحرك soyuz الآن خلال فترة
الضغط الديناميكي الأقصى
الذي يكون أسرع من الصوت كما هو  ds down range
soyuz الذي يسافر بسرعة 2500
ميل في الساعة على ارتفاع 15 ميلاً في الارتفاع الآن 10
أميال أسفل نطاق بايكونور كوزمودروم ،
تم الإبلاغ عن جميع المعلمات لتكون طبيعية من
قبل مهندسي منزل الكتلة في
بايكونور بينما نحن نقف على أهبة الاستعداد
لإغلاق المرحلة الأولى والفصل
و  لدينا المرحلة الأولى من إيقاف تشغيل
محركات المرحلة الثانية وتشغيلها في
حالة
جيدة ، حيث تم الإبلاغ عن أن الرحلة تسير
بطريقة اسمية ،
حيث تم الإبلاغ عن المعلمات الهيكلية الجيدة ، حيث
تقوم المرحلة الثانية من soyuz
بتوجيه تقدم سفينة إعادة الإمداد على مسار دقيق
إلى مدارها
الأولي ولدينا  تقارير مسار الإطلاق
تتخلى عن
جميع معلمات السيارة بحالة
جيدة أداء محرك جيد من
محركات المرحلة الثانية
وهذا المنظر من كاميرا على المرحلة العليا
من
soyuz 2.1a تسافر السويوز الآن بسرعة حوالي 7300
ميل في الساعة
81 ميلاً في  ارتفاع 190 ميلًا
بعيدًا عن قاعدة بايكونور كوزمودروم
، يستمر محرك المرحلة الثانية في
العمل بشكل طبيعي.
يتم الإبلاغ عن المعلمات
ونحن على أهبة الاستعداد
لإغلاق المرحلة الثانية وفصل
جميع التقارير الجيدة الواردة من
منزل الكتلة في بايكونور ،
حيث يتم الإبلاغ عن المعلمات الهيكلية الجيدة ،
وتستمر الرحلة أه للمضي قدمًا بطريقة
اسمية ،  التقارير
الواردة من
بايكونور حيث تستمر سويوز في أداء وظيفتها
جيدًا في منتصف الطريق خلال صعودها
لوضع التقدم على طريق
أداء محرك المرحلة الثالثة لمحطة الفضاء الدولية
وتشغيله في حالة جيدة مع عبور
علامة سبع دقائق في  رحلة
حوالي دقيقة واحدة و 40 ثانية من
الرسوم المتحركة المتبقية للرحلة التي تعمل بالطاقة يتم إنشاؤها الآن بواسطة
القياس عن بعد في الوقت الفعلي أه
من معزز soyuz 2.1a
لأننا على بعد حوالي دقيقة و 15
ثانية من إيقاف تشغيل المرحلة الثالثة
وفصل المركبة الفضائية
، يسافر معزز soyuz تقريبًا
13000 ميل في الساعة ، 122 ميل في الارتفاع
أكثر من 600 ميل من
محرك بايكونور كوزمودروم
المرحلة الثالثة يستمر في  احترق
بطريقة مثالية
بينما نعبر علامة الثماني دقائق ،
يتم الإبلاغ عن سيارة مستقرة جيدة
بمجرد أن
ينفصل التقدم عن
التحكم في المرحلة الثالثة للرحلة ، سيعود التقدم
إلى مركز التحكم في المهمة الروسي في
كارايوف خارج موسكو
نحن  الوقوف الآن لإغلاق المرحلة الثالثة
وفصل المركبات
الفضائية ولدينا إيقاف تشغيل للمرحلة الثالثة
والفصل
سيكون الحدث التالي هو نشر
المصفوفات الشمسية المتقدمة والهوائيات الملاحية
وترى هذه الوظيفة قيد العمل
الآن وقد تم الآن نشر جميع الملحقات
الأشعة الشمسية
للهوائي الملاحي وطفرة التلفزيون
أثناء التقدم ،
إطلاق مثالي وركوب مثالي لإطلاق مداره الأولي الذي
يحدث في الساعة 8 51 و 41 ثانية
مساءً
بالتوقيت المركزي 9 51 41 بالتوقيت الشرقي
، رحلة جيدة صعودًا على soyuz 2.1a Booster
وبالتالي فإن مطاردة التقدم جارية الآن
للوصول إلى محطة الفضاء الدولية
مع الالتحام المقرر في الساعة 12 12 صباحًا
بالتوقيت المركزي
1 12 صباحًا شرقًا  الوقت الحالي
وهكذا ، بعد حوالي ساعة
أو نحو ذلك من شروق الشمس في
بايكونور كوزمودروم في كازاخستان ،
استقل معزز soyuz 2.1a رحلة
لإيصال مركبة
إعادة الإمداد التقدمية ، سفينة إعادة الإمداد 75
إلى مدار مثالي ، مدار أولي ،
سلسلة من
عمليات إطلاق المحرك المبرمجة مسبقًا  المحرك
يحترق
الآن سنرفع التقدم
كمدار ونضعه على طريق
للوصول إلى محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
هناك أول نظرة لنا من خلال
تقدم كاميرا التلفزيون الخارجية ،
جميع أنظمة التقدم في
حالة ممتازة
، تقدم 2.78 طن من
الوقود الغذائي  والتجهيزات لسكان
محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
سنعود على الهواء في الساعة 11:30 مساءً بالتوقيت
المركزي 12:30 صباحًا بالتوقيت الشرقي
مع موعد تغطية
الالتحام والرسو مرة أخرى في الساعة 12 12 صباحًا بتوقيت
وسط 1
12 صباحًا بالتوقيت الشرقي صباح يوم السبت
لذا عد معنا في غضون ساعتين
وانضم إلى تغطيتنا مرة أخرى في ذلك الوقت
حتى ذلك الحين ، هذا هو التحكم في المهمة
[موسيقى]
هيوستن
[موسيقى  ]
التالي
[موسيقى]
دعنا نذهب
إليك